welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition in the first look
at Jared Oreos Morbius has leaked online
up top the image won't be in this video
or just because websites Twitter
accounts and the internet in general is
getting snapped left right and center
for using it I have however link to a
Twitter account that's posted it in the
description below so you can click that
now or at the end of the video and come
back for our thoughts and how we think
this will be revealed in the film
obviously huge huge spoilers here so if
you don't want what is a pretty big
review wound then I highly suggest that
you turn off now without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into
our breakdown okay so the look of
Morbius is pretty bang on exactly how
the character looks in the comic books
similar to venom Sony have managed to
capture the look of the antihero and
bring him to the big screen in a way
that I think comic book fans will be
very happy with even just looking at it
next to the comic book panel I have on
screen now you can see they went back to
the source material in order to bring a
really true vision of the living vampire
to audiences I'm really happy with how
the character looks but I have seen some
people saying it looks trash this is
mainly due to the facial hair element on
Morbius and this kind of reminds me a
bit of Cesar Romero when he played Joker
in case you don't know Caesar refused to
shave his mustache when playing the
Clown Prince of Crime and thus he just
walked around with it plastered on under
the makeup you could kind of get away
with it then because the show was a
campy Batman property but here it does
look a bit weird so yeah if you don't
like that aspect of the look then fair
enough maybe Leo just didn't want to
shave his beard like who knows maybe
that's the look of the character we
don't know yet now we did see behind the
scenes images recently of Jared Leo
looking normal so this will likely be a
transformation in the movie that happens
throughout it this was sort of how venom
was handled with Tom Hardy becoming
infected with the symbiote and then
slowly teasing the character before he
came out fully feels like Sony are
getting it together right now and I am
really really excited for the movie as
for the trailer itself it has now been
righted and will be getting released
imminently
though we don't know exactly when it's
out till it's out the buzz going around
the internet is that the trailer will be
released on Monday sony trailers tend to
release at 2:00 p.m. GMT which
translates to 9:00 a.m. Eastern Time in
6 a.m. Pacific time so yeah lots of hype
is building up to it now with the
release of this first look and I am
excited to see what the movies like I
actually liked venom and I loved into
the spider verse so I do have faith that
Sony can pull this off
anyway we will see but fingers crossed
this video doesn't get removed let me
know in the comments below as well if
the link doesn't work and I'll have a
look for another one but yeah
Soniya shutting this down at the moment
so I wouldn't be surprised
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the first look do you think it will
suck cuz cuz vampires suck or is les
more beer suit comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please give a thumbs up make sure you
check out our full breakdown of the news
that Scott Derrickson has stepped away
from the directing chair of Doctor
Strange you want to come chat to me
after the video that make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey I head over to my discord server
which should be linked in the
description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully
see you over there very soon this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
you